bonjour Clémentine Autain bonjour Merci
d'être invité ce matin débuter la France
insoumise de la Seine pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de Ouest-France bonjour
Stéphane bonjour on va évidemment parler
longuement de la locution d'Emmanuel
Macron vous allez nous dire ce que vous
en avez pensé que les ventilotins le
chef de l'État qui a reconnu qu'à
l'évidence la réforme des retraites n'a
pas été acceptée par les Français il a
admis la colère ça va dans le bon sens
pour vous vous plaisantez franchement
d'ailleurs depuis hier je suis
admirative de voir le temps passé sur
toutes les antennes à commenter le vide
c'est un exercice qui est pas forcément
évident même si c'est un vide signifiant
et vous aurez remarqué que sur les 13
minutes d'allocution de président de la
République seul deux minutes ont été
consacrés aux retraites où il a commencé
par nous réexpliquer ce qu'ils
expliquent depuis maintenant deux mois
et demi voire trois mois que la crise
sur les retraites est enclenchée et vous
imaginez bien que c'est pas avec ces
mêmes arguments qu'il va convaincre les
Français qui sont vent debout et il le
sait il n'a pas de légitimité il n'a pas
d'autorité sur ce sujet puisque les
Français ont dit non par tous les biais
ou c'était possible de s'exprimer
démocratiquement il a commencé par les
syndicats les syndicats ont dit non il y
a eu des millions de gens dans la rue et
des enquêtes d'opinion qui désignent
après les autres ont montré que cette
Français sur dix n'en voulait pas et
même neufactifs sur 10 et enfin à
l'Assemblée nationale comme il n'y avait
pas de majorité qu'elle était
introuvable il a décidé de pas faire le
vote du Parlement de celle de savoir
Monsieur le Sénat n'est pas l'Assemblée
nationale c'est quand même pas rien pas
l'Assemblée nationale qui ne vote pas
donc il ne tire aucune légitimité
d'aucun des biais démocratiques de ce
pays il avance avec la brutalité avec
l'autorité que lui permet la Cinquième
République parce que c'est ça le
problème dans les commentaires j'entends
beaucoup sa psychologie et c'est vrai
qu'elle est elle était quand même assez
incroyable il n'y a qu'à voir cette
phrase sur les 100 jours on se dit avec
tous les communiquants qu'il a autour de
lui toutes les équipes de gens qui ont
fait Léna et qui en épargne qui lui dit
écoute les 100 jours c'est grave ça se
termine à Waterloo à Sainte-Hélène
comment est-il possible qu'il est mis
son allocution sous le signe de ces de
ses 100 jours c'est délire bon il le
fait mais je pense que au-delà de la
psychanalyse qu'on peut faire
éventuellement du président de la
République ou l'analyse sociologique à
faire ben je l'entends beaucoup et c'est
vrai c'est vrai qu'à un moment donné on
se demande parce qu'il est tellement
hors-sol tellement déconnecté tellement
dans un délire de toute puissance qu'il
y a forcément une dimension
psychanalytique mais ce qui nous
intéresse nous c'est comment des
institutions permettent cette situation
normalement nous devrions avoir un
système institutionnel qui empêche un
homme seul de décider contre son peuple
c'est pourquoi nous sommes dans une
crise de régime et je pèse mes mots
c'est un des problèmes c'est que notre
Constitution est trop robuste elle
permet président de la République de
gouverner de alors qu'il n'a plus la
majorité mais vous savez elle a été
construite par un général pour un autre
contexte précisément mais ça fait 60 ans
qu'elle est là et au démarrage on était
en temps de guerre c'était la guerre
d'Algérie et il s'agissait pour le
général de Gaulle justement de créer
soi-disant la stabilité et de lui
permettre d'avancer loin de la quatrième
où il y avait un pouvoir
auprès c'est un régime hyper
présidentiel qui est une anomalie une
anomalie en Europe mais même à travers
le monde aucun régime démocratique nos
confrères un tel pouvoir à un seul homme
et quand il y a pas de majorité ça n'est
pas la minorité qui gouverne on cherche
des coalitions partout dans toutes les
démocraties
[Musique]